So let's now talk about the embrace of let
him die by the Republican Party.
Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick of Texas,
a Republican, of course.
He's scaling up his war on commonsense and
his war on responsibility.
He now says, hey, listen, with this Corona
virus thing and, you know, opening the country,
there are more important things than living
to which I would say for who?
Here he is on Tucker Carlson's program.
Last night, I believe it was.
But let's face reality of where we are.
In Texas, we have twenty nine million people
we've lost.
Four hundred and ninety five.
And every life is valuable.
But five hundred people out of twenty nine
million.
And we're locked down and we're crushing the
average worker.
We're crushing small business.
We're crushing the markets.
We're crushing this country.
And what I said when I was with you that night,
there are more important things than living.
And that's saving this country for my children,
my grandchildren, and saving this country
for all of us.
And I don't want to die.
Nobody wants to die.
But, man, we've got we've got to take some
risk and get back in the game and get this
country back up and running.
So was he refers to there.
He did previously say he'd be willing to sacrifice
himself for the economy.
And like I said before, that's fine if he
wants to sacrifice himself.
But it's not up to him to sacrifice other
people for what he sees as saving the economy.
Usually when they say save the economy.
They really just mean the stock market.
And it's similar here when Dan Patrick says
there are more important things than living.
What he really means is there are more important
things to him than other people living.
What is more important than living to individuals?
Now, there's another level of irony that I
would be remiss if I didn't mention today
about Dan Patrick.
We can't ignore Dan Patrick's position on
abortion.
If we are going to seriously analyze what
he is saying about Corona virus, Dan Patrick
says, In the context of opening barbershops,
there are more important things than living.
We've got to get the barbershop open.
Living is less important.
But when it comes to abortion, Dan Patrick
believes ending a pregnancy at eight weeks,
when you're talking about a clump of cells,
that's murder.
He campaigned on ending abortion.
And then he flippantly says, you know, if
a few tens of thousands of grandparents have
to die, maybe even hundreds of thousands for
the stock market, there are more important
things than living.
But if a clump of cells at eight weeks exists,
it must be protected as if it were the Secret
Service protecting the life of a president.
The guy's a hypocrite.
He doesn't appear to be a particularly good
person either.
And once again, with the religious right,
there is nothing more important than people
until they are born, at which point it's OK
to go without health insurance.
It's OK to go without food.
It's OK to go without education, because we've
got to prop up the profits of all of these
industries.
They don't care if you have to die to save
the Dow from dropping three extra points.
But if you want to have an abortion, they
decide not the women and the people that would
be part of those individual decisions between
patients and doctors.
This is what's so difficult about fighting
this.
They have the wrong moral code.
They're wrong on the facts and they don't
care.
It's very difficult to fight against people
who share those characteristics.
How do you fight someone whose entire frame
of reference and factual basis is not only
incoherent, it's wrong and it indicates that
they are not empathetic people.
It's a very, very difficult.
The only real way to fight them is overwhelm
them with votes at the ballot box in November.
As we've been speaking about yesterday and
today during the interview segment with Rachel
Bittar, Coffer convincing people to change
their mind is not an effective way to win
elections.
It's particularly ineffective.
When their moral code seems to be fundamentally
malfunctioning to them, it seems to work,
but to us it seems to be fundamentally malfunctioning.
We've got to just find people and get them
to vote because these people are not going
to come around.
Somebody who hears Dan Patrick say, listen,
barbershops are more important than grandma
living up.
But don't you dare even think about getting
yourself an abortion.
There's no arguing with those people.
There just isn't.
We've got to overwhelm them
at the
ballot box.